hello and welcome to this video playing
schengen 2013 until a king's indian
player it seems going for Kings Indian
cell drive some tweets I play
yeah black has many um possible setups
in with 565 9696 here that I have never
seen but it cannot be that terrible of
course directed at least against the
before pre move it's not a big fan of
putting on ports in the center it seems
and now he tries mmm interesting way I
can just can just oops sorry keep the
tension doesn't look bad at putting
pressure against this b7 pawn
so just d4 okay yeah what's the best
square b2b one even be five I suppose
maybe I so that Knight b6 can be
answered with going to be three which
doesn't really seem to irritate them a
lot just wants to go back
PS to go back
okay so Bishop d7 sorry Bishop e7 Bishop
takes bishop takes rook takes its night
c 5 i'm not sure about this at least he
gets some gets rid of some of those
clumsy pieces think i just get more into
play here d 5 bow
okay um
the piece has no square absolutely no
square you could have gone to e6 that
wasn't all that terrible
okay he's got an idea for check okay
let's just let's go back with the king
step out are those possible checks yeah
if i move the night before somewhat
vulnerable but this is the case anyway
not much to do about it
here can actually take with the rook and
not loose material immediately let me do
it
you
okay i hope i really i know we can i I
really hate this this the way I'm
playing at dawn it's just so atrocious
Bishop g5 I think I'm winning Bishop c4
blob you're even losing here probably
after this complete joke of the game
when you just blundered the night for
nothing yeah this is really it's a bad
position it's just a bad position ah God
time morning absolutely not coordinated
he a tall ship deform and then I'm toast
great stuff great stuff we should before
I resign ok it doesn't see it maybe this
is also losing I don't know okay to look
everyone I think even wince again
check
I look at you again sir okay 21 i think
i could take f6a come on I should just
quit this bloody game it's amazing it's
really amazing can I do this so I can
just go back I'm sick of this this game
probably had as many mistakes as it had
moves
check check check check check check
we're getting a draw here check check
check check mate no words oh wow this is
probably I mean maybe like 20 ? so again
I mean okay it all starts with blacks
very very weird opening play where you
basically just lose this I mean he moves
the Knights around and gives me
everything week p 7 square center and so
on it gives me two moves there and then
yeah this is just blundering the night
for nothing here was very close playing
Bishop g5 blundering everything yeah and
here and then Bishop g5 oh my god you
can play whatever I am Bishop f4 it's
just a piece really no play this and
yeah i'm here i'm just here I'm just
losing I guess be five horse whinnying
already know but this also should yeah
this was made yeah this was shine made
that he that he could play this was
check mate
instead roo k 8 and the game somehow
continues then I played Bishop I have
six which is also double ? check rook a
to now chance I didn't do that look a
three wins but okay this also is winning
of course he's material ok Queen d5
would have been a draw and looking at
this with the computers kind of has some
comedy value check ya champion I'm just
made you with a couple of shine a couple
of ways check check check check ya book
a one is chick made and here I'm meeting
him yeah this is my check check check
check oops check oh my what a disgusting
game okay thanks for watching